[موسيقى]
نادرًا ما تجتمع الطبيعة والعمارة
معًا بشكل مثالي ، حيث أن
الأديرة اليونانية الإلهية في ميتيورا ميتيورا هي
مجموعة من الأديرة الأرثوذكسية اليونانية التي
تطفو على أعمدة صخرية على
ارتفاع 1300 قدم فوق سطح الأرض ، وقد
بناها رهبان يونانيون من القرن الرابع عشر إلى
القرن السادس عشر.
شيدت باستخدام شبكة من
بكرات الحبال والسلالم التي رفعت
المؤن فوق المنحدرات الدرامية
بالإضافة إلى العزلة ، فقد
جلب الموقع للرهبان والسكان المحليين مكانًا
للحماية من المتعدين غير المرغوب فيهم
وملاذًا أثناء غزوات
الأتراك اليوم ستة فقط من الأصل
بقي 20 ديرًا ، لكنهم ما زالوا
يسكنهم 20 راهبًا وأربع راهبات
مقيمين بدوام كامل ، وماي تيارا هي
واحدة من عدد قليل من الأماكن
المدرجة كموقع للتراث العالمي لليونسكو
تحت فئتين: الطبيعة والفن
دون تغيير  تمكن الرهبان
من بناء أديرة تبدو
وكأنها امتدادات
للجبل نفسه  يترجم e meteora إلى معلق
في الفضاء ويبدو أن هذه الأديرة
تتحدى الجاذبية حقًا
[موسيقى]